The Game of Thrones stars are finally able
to speak out about how this blockbuster fantasy
series came to a close, and while some are
happy with their endings, others, particularly
the Mother of Dragons, seem to be less than
thrilled.
Throughout her run on Thrones, Emilia Clarke
has taken Daenerys Targaryen from a naïve,
frightened child bride to a formidable and
lethal dragon queen, but underneath it all,
Daenerys has had to juggle her desire for
justice with her genetic makeup.
After all, she is the daughter of the infamous
Mad King, Aerys II Targaryen.
Even so, audiences have always rooted for
Daenerys, cheering her on as she frees slaves,
saves innocents, and fights those in power
to give it to those below, until the end of
season eight.
Daenerys' torching of King's Landing during
the penultimate episode, "The Bells," wasn't
entirely unexpected, but her descent into
madness was seen as abrupt and unearned, as
if viewers were supposed to forget about Daenerys'
humanity and believe she would kill thousands
of innocent people without a passing thought.
For her part, Clarke might have tried to warn
audiences about this before the season aired.
In 2018, Clarke revealed to Vanity Fair that
her final scenes were incredibly upsetting
and that fans might look at Daenerys differently,
given that her continued passion for war leads
to Jon Snow ultimately having to kill her.
During an Emmys event before the final season
premiered, it's hard to overlook her facial
expression:
"Best season ever!"
Other actors have expressed some frustrations
about the final season, too.
They include...
One of the most compelling, infuriating, evil,
and dynamic characters on Game of Thrones
is Cersei Lannister, thanks in no small part
to the performance of Lena Headey.
Even as Cersei committed unspeakable atrocities,
killing anyone and destroying everything in
her path to make sure the Lannisters stayed
in power, fans were occasionally swayed thanks
to the heart and depth Headey put into Cersei's
character.
Fans expected an ending for Cersei that was
as sensational as Headey's performance.
Unfortunately, Cersei's grand exit didn't
pan out as planned.
While fans were mulling over theories that
ranged from everything from death by Jaime's
golden hand to Arya or the Hound killing Cersei,
they were ultimately given a sequence in which
Cersei and twin brother Jaime are crushed
by bricks in each others' arms in the bottom
of the Red Keep.
Even Headey was annoyed at this closing scene,
saying she wanted something bigger or any
sort of fight at all.
As freed slave Missandei, Nathalie Emmanuel
brought a considerable amount of heart to
an often cruel show.
Fans loved her friendship with Daenerys as
well as her relationship with Grey Worm, the
leader of the Unsullied army, but grew apprehensive
when Missandei and Grey Worm started to make
plans for the future, always a bad sign.
Missandei ended up captured by Cersei's forces,
and was beheaded in front of Daenerys in a
show of cruelty and power.
After the episode, Emmanuel said that it was
disappointing to see the show's one woman
of color killed so abruptly.
She also spoke to the emotional weight of
Missandei dying in chains, which brought her
full circle in the most heartbreaking way
possible.
Fans and critics agreed with Emmanuel, and
it seems there's no shortage of viewers who
think there should have been more justice
for the character.
One of the most mysterious and interesting
characters in Thrones, Lord Varys, played
by Conleth Hill, seemed to know every secret
in all of Westeros.
Though Varys began the series firmly in the
Lannister camp, he eventually switched sides
to join his friend Tyrion Lannister in Daenerys'
court.
Having known Daenerys' dangerous father, he
remained cautious.
After Missandei's execution, he concocted
a plan to tell the Seven Kingdoms about the
true heir to the throne, Jon Snow, only to
be found out and burned alive at Daenerys'
order.
After Varys' death, Hill told Entertainment
Weekly that he was upset by the last couple
of seasons.
He was disappointed that the showrunners couldn't
devise a final meeting between Varys and Littlefinger,
considering that the two characters often
worked together to pull the strings.
He added that he wasn't sure the series successfully
moved past author George R.R. Martin's source
material.
"Are you all happy...with the outcome of the
show?
Personally?"
By season eight, Tyrion Lannister had been
Daenerys' top advisor for quite some time,
but in her eyes, he'd begun to falter.
Between underestimating his sinister sister
Cersei and being too trusting of his brother
Jaime, relations between the Dragon Queen
and her Hand were splintering.
Actor Peter Dinklage certainly has a good
relationship with his character, but has also
made not-so-subtle hints at his frustration
with how the show ended.
In a video about the end of the show, he criticized
the decision to put all the women and children
in a crypt full of the dead during the Battle
of Winterfell, but the most telling moment
comes when Entertainment asked how
he felt about the ending:
"There are no better writers in television
than Dan Weiss and David Benioff...You people
are in for it."
Some fans described the interview as a, quote,
"hostage video."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.